I can just reflect money but today you
know we uh we were out there running
around today on our conditioning day
gosh still got his wheels I'm proud of
him on that and we still compete you
know I know that fire still burns in the
deep he's still a little in his own way
make sure that he'll still try and win
in every facet so he's the most
competitive person I've met and yes I
always expect the most out of them
because I know that he can at least for
my expectations that he can doesn't run
that in the throwing skills of Aaron
Rodgers often obscure the reality that
he does indeed have wheels that was
David Baca tre complimenting his
quarterback who is 36 I remember when I
was a kid there was this loose sense
when you get into early 30s mid thirties
you lose that ability to run like you
used to this guy's gonna be 37 in
December Chris well how do you see his
ability to run in comparison to the way
that he used to be well he's he's one of
the greatest scramblers of all time I
mean and he's you know he's been a very
effective runner as a quarterback
throughout his career
I mean 2016 he was second on his team in
rushing and led his team in rushing
touchdowns and he pulled a calf muscle
towards the end of the year he probably
would have led his team in rushing so
that just tells you about his wheels I
will say this I thought last year was
the first time I thought I saw him lose
a step and his ability to get away from
defenders when he did want to break the
pocket and run but I still think his
mobility is above average for the NFL
starter and really his greatest gift is
the quickness of his feet Mike and how
we watch him hop around hop around hop
around and then zoom there goes one of
those lasers that I love he still has
that ability that's for sure and the
challenge for him as he does start to
lose a half step here or a half step
there is to adjust his awareness in
relation to where everyone else is and
how quickly they're closing on him so he
gets down gets out of bounds gets rid of
the football
cuz the window that that clock is going
to shrink and that's an important point
for Aaron Rodgers he gets closer to four
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports